I've had some,
I had some conflicts online.
One of them with a,
a bunch of vegans.
They,
so you entertain somebody,
you're trying to be you like,
I don't got time for that,
I'm not going to entertain.
But every once while you just want to punch a troll in the phages would read the
comments.
That was the problem is that occasionally you read the comments are like Holy
Shit,
like people just want you dead.
Because anyway,
I had this whole thing in my act about chasing down the Hashtag Vegan cat.
Somebody wrote to mean shit to me and had this Hashtag Vegan cattle.
It's like,
what the fuck is that?
I went there and there's a whole community of people feeding their cats
vegetables and but,
but in,
in doing this and like tracking this down and Che and like it,
it makes you realize like,
okay,
I gotta write a bit about this.
Cause I could just get mad.
Easily writes,
it writes itself.
I could just get mad and be upset that someone's being mean to me or to turn
this shit into fuel.
Or You could just go,
fuck it.
Just destroy the whole Vegan community.
There's nothing,
it's not the feet.
It's nothing wrong with vegans.
Is his the same shit every other group.
I don't really know too many vegans that aren't assholes,
Bro.
I know some vegans.
It aren't assholes.
I don't know.
Rich Roll.
He's a great guy off John Joseph.
He's a great guy.
Neal Brennan.
He's a Vegan.
He's an asshole.
He's a little bit of an ass phone man.
Neil Brennan is a mother fucking prick.
What are you talking about man?
He's still telling people to turn into s when it,
the asshole is in him.
Especially people wear glasses because they were,
they have like million different frames.
That's when you had the next level of being an asshole when you switch your
glasses up.
But Neil Brennan is a Vegan.
He's one of those.
I don't think vegans should be allowed to go to a barbecue and complain.
They complain.
They all come to a fucking barbecue.
They got the patties,
they upset.
If you've been cooking meat on a grill that was designed to cook dead animals,
they'll sort don't get up and they get upset.
So all vegans are assholes.
I'm sorry this is not all of them,
but I see what you're saying.
All the ones that I know it did it because it cause when I made them,
but they made the transition.
It can't just become vegans.
They got,
they just got to let you know I'm Vegan now.
They can't wait.
You say dinner?
Is it Vegan options?
It Vegan,
Vegan.
They just can't do it.
They got to make an announcement.
I think I let everybody know that I'm a Vegan and now and I'm an asshole.
They think they're saving the world and the worst is a Vegan that always gets
cold.
Yo,
whenever I see Neil,
Brittney coffin,
whatever,
I see a car.
I say,
so how's that big a live call?
You fucking flew habitats by the fuck.
How he say that to Ian Edwards?
I'm like,
dude,
you look tired.
Exhausted.
I take pictures of each and every time we fly together and he falls asleep.
I take pictures of me and just sit there.
I'm like,
well the fucking protest.
I mean I'd have be 12,
and your diet get a stake in your motherfucking daddy.
He said he would eat meat,
but he would only eat elk that I killed.
He said he would eat some,
uh,
some elk meets.
I'm going to cook him some elk meat.
We're going to,
we should film it.
It probably like bounce around like super person.
Like he's been eating nothing but lentils for the last 20 years.
El Cutoff.
Where does one go to even shoot an elk?
Utah.
Colorado has a lot of them.
There's some of them.
How do you transport?
Is there loss?
Can you transport your killer?
You have to break it down wherever.
Where have you killed it?
You law,
you have to have,
uh,
first of all you have a tag and then when you,
when you have a tag,
you're allowed to get a certain kind of animal.
So say if it's like,
uh,
you have,
a buck deer tag,
that means you can kill a male deer.
And then once you kill it,
then you break it down and you either bring it to a butcher shop and they turn
it into cuts for you.
Or You could do it yourself and wrap it up,
but you have to have a tag and you have to register that you killed that animal
and you have to keep that,
that that with you,
that paperwork with you.
So if you transport the meat across state lines and some game warden pulled you
over and did you have a deer in your car and you were,
yes,
I do,
sir.
He's got to see that you have the paperwork for it.
I don't want to sell races and all,
but I don't know a black person that could tell that story that you just about
killing.
Butchering up to transport.
Yeah.
That's what you have to do.
That's how you do it.
You got to put them on ice.
I mean,
you have to,
you have an obligation to try to save the meat.
You know you,
when you have an animal and it's down,
you want to get it into like a packaged form as quick as possible.
You want to break it down.